advances to the playoffs as the seven
seed Bay Lines it up too strong
offensive rebound Collins bounces for
Bay who slams it down
it's the same highlight over and over
again for the Hawks hero shows
defensively Murray fends him off shot
clock is down to three Murray crosses
Murray tough
Tufts are cooking
Murray the jumper shortened rebound
again the Hawks have it Collins scores
in the foul Atlanta advances to the NBA
playoffs
[Applause]
[Music]
116 to 105.
the Hawks will be the seventh seed they
will meet the Boston Celtics in the
first round Miami is going to have to
get it done on Friday night good stuff
there Chris good reporting that'll be
something to watch for sure Lowry coming
off a 33-point game Tuesday here's
DeRozan again he found and the shooters
bounce on cue DeMar DeRozan kick and
roll over the top Butler able to drive
away and not a big steal Martin running
with him Butler takes it himself
[Applause]
[Music]
Caruso it goes and one for Jimmy buckets
for five for three tonight six for 17
overall big struggle for him just 15
points Jimmy Butler leaves it looks
Bruce his first point to the second half
time out Bulls who says the screener for
Butler and force a switch
[Applause]
the jumper
Jimmy Butler Levine Autumn Butler spins
nothing there Butler space
[Applause]
that's just a great move
is able to step through on Levine
and then take the contact from buchevich
and finish let's match up great defender
great playmaker
gives it up Max Cruz for three
and now he's trying to send the Bulls
Home 12-1 Run for the heat Levine goes
quick blocks and a foul on white Miami
ball
great block here by out of bio and you
gotta love what bam out of Bio has done
tonight because it's been a rough night
for him offensively at the end of the
year those guys haven't played a game in
quite a while look for Miami to have a
great shot in game one in Milwaukee
that's it the Miami Heat
they will advance they will occupy the
eighth seed as they come out of the
play-in and now they will take on the
top seed the Milwaukee Bucks
[Music]
Lopez with it he traveled and Hiro is
holding on to his hand
[Applause]
he's on his way back to the locker room
he just
he's out he ran right to the locker room
rebound chased and saved by low parents
and intercepted by Robinson Lowry to
Butler and Butler pull jump over the
holidays
39 shot clock at nine Middleton with
Butler driving right into it count it
down
with the honors there
[Applause]
it's loose
and Giannis was trying to call time out
but Kyle Lowry and his intensity and
defense created another turnover
will take it in out to Martin thinks it
now Fires at it
46 points for Jimmy Butler
[Applause]
why not
or he's going to get an easy lay-in
this is the one they called a long tune
for Butler so that's why you attack
early here
scores correct Giannis with the ball
outside
[Applause]
Jimmy Butler the other way
and he's gonna win it
and goes up three games to one and the
number one seed is on the brink of
elimination
and Jimmy Butler a historic 56 Point
performance
in this game four didn't take any of the
baits finish it off with the defensive
rebound textbook
Butler is inside again and one oh wow
these Miami Heat will not go away
[Applause]
here we go
holiday delivers
Here Comes Vincent that you can't do
with foul
over Matthews and good wow Gabe Vincent
big shot from Gabe he's got 22. that's a
postseason career high oh no they're
coming over they turn it over Lowry had
it and he lost it who's I think the
foul's on Middleton they call him on
Lowry I think that's the way the
defender gets his hand on the ball and
deflects it away this is a legal
defensive play by Kyle Lowry the
challenge is successful what season on
the line
[Applause]
[Music]
came right over at us
[Applause]
and right here Giannis didn't want to
get fouled so he hoppitated it and
Middleton with the play of the game
which was safe it has to be great
Jesus
over the top to Butler
Jimmy Butler what's going on is Jimmy
Butler
and overtime in game five
Jimmy Butler runs a little bit of a
circle cut looks like he's going to go
to the corner circles back and it's a
live play
but he couldn't keep it in bounds it's
back to Miami
inside seller with the flush and that
was all off the Jimmy Butler cut
two-point game Butler steps in front
shot
and the Miami Heat become the sixth in
NBA history to win as an eighth seed in
the first round tough
trying to ice it and send him to the
Baseline he gets to the middle whistle
foul and did he turn his ankle on that
boy we hope not but he's holding his
lower right leg and Butler it appeared
as if he turned it Doris
yeah saw that happen in real time
and this does not look good
for Miami
here's Lowry seven on the shot clock
they got to get to work off the out of
Bio screen
tough Baseline got it come on Kyle Lowry
the veteran and finish that even though
it was a difficult shot inside one point
game Nick's in front Randall backing in
off the double team jumper heart splash
all right
[Applause]
kicks it out quickly short on the three
got his own Miss puts it back up and in
great hustle and contact under the
basket temper's player which we expected
at some point in this series security
gets on the floor exposed her out there
as well peeling his player Cody Martin
away from hardenstein now Tom Thibodeau
is walked down Court
see also that Zeller was in that
crime trying to fight through that
market screen Butler kick Martin tribe
on a rack attack Caleb Martin
this is not a replay over and over again
it's the same story Butler gets to the
rim
112 to go Butler trapped finds Vincent
Vincent on the attack at a bio the slam
front to the inbound gets it to Randall
gets it right back fronts it bounces
underneath and Horton lays it in it's a
two-point game not one to give up a
three at any cost Brunson
spinning brunch in leaning shoveling
into traffic he turned it over Brunson
turns it over and Butler is down Spruce
gets it ahead here is Vincent
and that is it
the Miami Heat has done it yet again
they are headed back to the Eastern
Conference Finals by five threes that
just doesn't happen to the Celtics
shot clock at three Butler with problem
it's a long three
[Applause]
freaking Butler puts it in and that'll
be number three shot clock running down
and it's the butler who did it
touches every inch of that rim
[Applause]
all right
the shot made by Williams and look at
the words already Williams and Jimmy
Butler is smiling about it and then
here's the contact at the ensuing play
and let's go head to head guys
thank you and the New York Knicks in the
second round Butler will take it into
the defense of Brett Williams shot clock
at four here he accelerates and finds
two oh and gave him the the two small
sign
out of Iowa screen Williams the
defensive assignment
inside for the lead that's what he wants
Grant Williams on him this shot clock at
three
Butler will chisel
oh my goodness
it's Gabe Jensen
setting up two-point shot good not Jimmy
Butler not bam out of Bio but Gabe
Vincent are you kidding me
[Music]
and he's pointing at Grant Williams on
the ground
pointing at Grant Williams on the
contact in the potential N1 great job
against the Zone though getting the ball
to Tatum right there at the Mayo and
then a great defensive play right here
in Hawaii
perfect
well that affects everything
Tatum he'll put up a three got
him and he knew there was no way that
Vincent was going to be able to contest
that shot oh my God this never happened
as we've mentioned multiple times a team
coming back down three games tonight and
again NBA playoff series we can't stress
enough four of the last five times
Boston's been in Miami's building they
have won coach four-point game watch
from the minutes ago
[Applause]
Patrick's his way inside
[Music]
pocket Ford Tatum inside what's the best
[Applause]
Robinson for the lead
rebound Tatum out to Smart
[Applause]
knocked away Robinson on the drive by
smart Butler has scored 10 of the last
12 points for Miami
defended by Horford
[Music]
to unpack here on this play by Jimmy
Butler certainly there's contact in the
foul by Al Horford it was called a two
on the floor but look at the feet of
Butler clearly in my opinion he's behind
the three-point line this should be
three clear throws Butler is also behind
the three-point line at the time
with four to play
to time
out shelter white will involved
[Applause]
[Music]
in put some buzzers sounded the light
was on it'll be reviewed
I don't think he got that in time great
effort by Derek white and didn't I say
you have their say it on the floor
they're counting it you have to protect
the offensive rebounding oh he got rid
of it
the Celtics are going to win there's a
game seven back in Boston Running on the
floor is good basket the plays under
review
it's a drive by Martin Horford was in
the way shot talking six twisting Tony
shooting got it as Jason Tatum switch on
it Jimmy Butler's got to understand
what's going on until half Joseph Tatum
on that switch oh get it to the guy
who's been the most consistent scorer in
this series Caleb Martin
but we're with Tatum defending outside
Martin makes the fake Williams beat the
three fools wow
[Applause]
[Music]
Boston Celtics in the lead for Miami
grows only after they have won three
straight games to start this series so
it was a game seven they stand eye to
eye with history and they did not blink
the heat are going to the NBA finals